[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Winter Invitational
that tradition continues hello chess
fans and welcome to another day of play
here at the Winter Invitational the GM
and I am norm tournament starting today
where we play rounds 4 & 5 we're going
to see the possible contenders get
whittled down the chances get less and
less for our GM and I am norm hopefuls
stick with us right here on YouTube as
we talk to some of the hopefuls some of
whom have come from all over the world
to participate in this truly
international event so as part of the GM
norm field we have one of the dream
crushers here the one and only celebrity
Grandmaster Ben Feingold then hello oh
you're talking to me sorry I was I was
just reading Twitter and Donald said my
games were the most exciting you know
we're going to have to edit that out now
so Ben you've had some really exciting
draws in this tournament I've had the
most exciting and actually the edlund's
had to come twice because people were
just fainting at the sight of my game
that's something like that that's what
we going on so unfortunately I don't
have any wins but fortunately I have no
losses so I did get it hold on I'm
getting another text right now a nice
Giri said good job ok so but he said
don't steal my thunder all right so I
have four draws out of four games not
for lack of trying but trying is the
first step to failure let's have a look
in chronological order my first game was
against Olivos Lopez I have a funny
story about him which takes about 20
minutes to tell non-paid I played him in
the pro chest league a few weeks ago and
he was destroying me and I found a
stalemate trick and he fell for it so a
solid draw very suspicious to now in
this game I decided to play a
the Kings Indian and then I changed my
mind as a board and I played Bishop f4
the London system which I probably
played once in my life maybe twice
usually I had black in this position
okay let's get to the interesting part
because the game was only ten moves
along so in this position
my opponent played 96 and I thought he
would play e5 at some points because he
played 96 and then he tricked me by
playing Knight h5 and he chased my
district around and we up in this really
interesting position here and I actually
thought about six minutes seven minutes
of this position and I didn't see any of
the engine analysis none of it you left
you a little bit okay so first of all
one of the engines claims after Knight
takes g5h takes g5 Bishop g5 Knight f6 h
for that white is better I would say
white is lost so White's got a piece
that confuses me what doesn't confuse me
is the corrections in this position
which is g4 are you watching that Larson
the answer is no now the point of g4 is
truthful longest time threatenings night
I didn't look at g4 at all never even
occurred to me I guess I should've been
thinking about Matt Larson if he plays
Knight f6 I saved my bishop I sacrificed
my Jeep lon I play h4 and his King to
get into some trouble so the main line
his Bishop to g4 then Knight takes g5
confusing the audience at home and you
and the reason the black can't win a
piece here is because of this position
even though black is ahead of piece
after rook g1 black's not very happy
because I'm threatening Queen g5 Queen
g4 and Queen xx and you can't defend
against all that and even if you could Y
could play like King e2 or castles and
just attack down the G line so this is
winning for Wyatt
after g4 the computer says white is at
point six which is a nice advantage I
didn't look at g4 for a second I played
Bishop g3 and offered a draw
and my opponent accepted even though he
was
probably about 20 minutes on the clock
at this point and of course the engine
says all zeros I think it was looking at
my IQ test or something all right now is
my first game then let's look at the
other games now round 2 was my most
interesting I guess from for many
perspectives I was black I'll flip the
board in case my comer watches the video
ok and I applied the French defense
which I usually don't play I did my
special preparation and I played the
Fort Knox variation which is to train
and play Bishop d7 to c6 and I noted in
my preparation for this opponent that he
had only faced this one single has
several heroes and in this game he
played a mu he didn't play which is very
rarely play which is very dangerous the
normal move addition to d3 which he's
played before and usually there's a lot
of trading going on you play ninety
seven you play Knight f6 and actually
the last norm tournament we had here a
few months ago I had this condition okay
my opponent played Knight eg5 and I went
into one of my big things I'm famous for
that and the main moves are Knight d7
and Bishop e7 I thought he would
sacrifice sign at 7 if I did that so I
played the moves I thought prevented the
sacrifice on f7 I played Bishop to d6 it
turns out sacrificing on f7 would have
gained they became really interesting
this was actually his preparation but he
forgot Bishop d6 cuz he prepared again
so many moves and this is a very
interesting line if you're just watching
the video now you'll think I can castle
but I can't because I played king f7
King yet by the way one of the Blitz
tournaments here in st. Louis that
didn't stop one of my opponents they
moved their King would get back and then
castle I claim to win okay and this
position is super complicated I think
the computer prefers white slightly okay
instead of sacrificing he played Bishop
to d3 and now after age six the
sacrifice doesn't make any sense because
he can't play Knight e5 or Knight g5 I'm
well protected so he had to go back to
e4 and I want to show you the whole deal
and play something pretty funny
after we traded in c6 excuse this
position on the screen right now I'm
actually two Tempe ahead of an
normal position this position after
Bishop to d3 there's again that Nakamura
one and many other grandmasters played
Bishop takes e4 this should take efore
c6 this is actually one of the main
lines in the game that I had I had this
exact position with the moves h6 and
Bishop d6 inserted so I'm playing a
theoretical line to Tempe ahead and I'm
still worth but I'm slightly worse then
we traded traded trade we both Castle
queenside a game was a draw one more
interesting thing about the game is we
learned afterwards that this position
here was played in the game Anand Karpov
a long time ago and that game they both
short castles and they drew but we're
more adventurous we both want castle
although he still drew that was my most
exciting game let's say wake up at home
you're falling asleep over there okay
and the last two games were not as
interesting
I played nikhil kumar the world under 12
champion and this was my prep i noticed
nikhil always plays the queen's gambit
to climb was Bishop e7 and all of his
opponents either played Bishop f4 or
they take on d5 then played Bishop f4
and I've never done that I've always
played Knight f3 and Bishop g5 I saw no
examples in my preparation for this
position and I've had this position a
million times even before he was born
and before you were born and before you
were born and so we got this position
which I prepared and here black has many
moves b6 e 696 he took on c4 which I've
also faced and in this position things
got boring pretty quickly and there was
a lot of trades and the games didn't get
very interesting until the very end
although I noticed you're copying and
pasting skills could use some more
because that's not the end of the game
sorry about that that's okay now in this
position we'll just skip over here after
lots of trades white at some point wants
to play Knight f5 or you could say it at
home say it with me knife f5 and mikheil
plays a very accurate Bishop c8 here
which stops Knight f5 because he can
take it and the game concluded very
peacefully I have to make that move
myself what kind of joint you run in
here and in this position after King F
Nikhil offered me a draw and the
computer says zero zero zero so I agreed
after consulting I didn't consult the
computer okay so that was a pretty
boring final position and if you thought
that was boring I got more boring for
you and it's like in with Cheka he took
the whole game this kind good job I
played white with E for which I rarely
do I plays the exchanged French I always
play Knight f3 here but here I played ki
for special preparation because as you
know been explosive c4 is explosive and
this was my prep and this was about I
looked at a lot of games of this line
and somehow this couldn't get very
exciting either we got a lot of trades
and I tried to avoid trades but then he
traded everything and at some point I
thought I was getting a worse position
so even though he was I was avoiding
trades here I thought I could get into
trouble because Queen b6 puts pressure
on my pawns and Queen a5 puts pressure
on my bishops so I was like alright
let's make this game a draw before I get
worse computer says I'm slightly worse
and I've played it and played Queen b3
basically solving all my problems my D
pawn cake had attacked my bishop on g5
isn't hanging and we have obviously
colored bishops and I offered a draw as
usual I was down 20 minutes on the clock
pretty good for me and my opponent who's
700 years younger than me accepted I'd
like to let you know at home the three
youngest players of the tournament in my
section if you had all of their ages up
I'm much older than that so it's not
fair it's not fair
okay so stay tuned next time when I come
back and I'll show you more drawings
well hold on Ben I'm not done with you I
want to I want to ask you I gotta ask
your what you're one of the big guys in
the top field yeah well yeah and I'm
little oh no one of those guys plays
along you're pretty big yeah I think so
yeah yeah so with these tournaments
you're essentially the dream Smasher
okay well you're one of them you're
supposed to be the guy who puts the hold
on these up-and-comers so what is the
incentive for you you just showed us
four draws you come here I'm good at
putting a hold on my comer on the up and
comer is not so good well normally when
I play in local yokel events I play a
lot of local yokels
so I'm playing players rated between
1400 and 2,000 a lot and I beat up on
them and that's not really good for
keeping sharp you want to play players
between 23 50 and 2600 which is in my
reading range a see if I can beat
anybody I think we know the answer to
that no of course I'm a professional
player so the more they pay the more I
play it's like pay to play wait pay to
play who would do that in politics Donna
so I want to play these guys when
they're twelve thirteen once they get to
fourteen I already can't beat them and
I've played two of the youngest players
in the tournament nickel is check up and
I played the world youth champion to
kill Kumar I got one left to wonder
Liang
we've played before it was a draw but
now I'm getting sort of worried because
he's about a year older than the last
time I played him that's not good so I
want to play the young players I want to
still keep in shape but normally instead
of getting my +2 and +3 that I got ten
twenty thirty years ago
now I'm getting minus one minus two so
50 percents pretty good for me do you
think that a no drawers before move 30
rule would benefit you or hinder you hmm
I've played in such tournaments but they
don't make any sense oh I play something
funny when I play draya's in the pro
chef league last week for our team's a
little starch bishops I didn't know what
move we were on because I was in focus
from which I'll show you the moves then
when the game ended I noticed that black
had bait is xxx blue of which is me and
we agreed to a draw and our Verdes dream
I don't think it would affect you too
much but I probably my results wouldn't
be better let's put it that way because
the more for our games I play the worst
I play we play two games a day for half
the tournament and I'm three times the
age of some of the players so playing
seven eight hours a day has been good
for my job two hours a day I can handle
that been in your field who do you see
as an emerging star in the world of
chess well Oh in chess
emerging star in chess while the young
guys obviously nicolas checque won
drilling and the kill Kumar those guys
are really young and really good the top
of their age category in the world world
youth champions a wonders won at least
twice maybe three times and those are
those are the up-and-coming guys like
eyes were eighty to nineteen hot
something hasn't retired yet what's
going on here
of course Tata have one today so she's
trying for an IM Energy I'm nor maybe
she can get both she's back at 50% she
had a bad tournament here last time
that's why you play again you can
improve from last tournament well then
thank you so much for joining us and we
look forward to seeing more of your
games in the tournament Thank You bud
for seven players the objective earn a
norm
however the means to doing that differs
for each player for six and a half
points Gor vet Liang Burke and a lemur
Andy can earn a GM norm for only 6
points Cheka and a bohemian can earn a
GM norm and additionally Believe It or
Not for four and a half points Kumar and
Abraham Yin are eligible for an IM norm
in this section in the second field the
IM norm tournament we have national
master aaron grab in ski here who's had
one heck of a day going to straight
aaron you just defeated international
master Angelo young first of all
congratulations take us through some of
the highlights of this game okay so I
knew he was going to play something
offbeat and sure enough Knight h5 so
that's very uh it's not very common
there should be five and then I got
really surprised after GC c6 for sure
it's a tricky move because if I play E
Street pretty obvious Queen a5 and I
lose a bishop and he protects his Knight
but after E for I don't see the point of
c6 it seems just wrong because now is
nice attacked anyway and if you plays
Knight back to f6 I gain more time by
playing e5 so you play g6 which I
expected this should be 2 and then 97
already move five his Knight it's being
keto so very very typical for Angelo I
would say I just kept developing we had
e5 so I thought f3 was good was it kind
of reminds me of the fantasy variation
in Carroll Collins but here it seems
even better because the knight of skiing
cut out so I was pretty sure here
already I had a much better position so
a three typical you know just so you can
take on be too because 94
expecially and here I realized that I
can hear I was thinking maybe I messed
up because it sounds like e5 you can
just take it and I'm pinned on eastery
and so this is a little annoying because
he has a lot of pressure on d4 but 984
and I can get out of it
pretty easily my pawn Center is very
strong so castles yeah I think a better
movement may have been b5 for example
let me just jump to that real quick he
plays b5 there's some interesting ideas
because I was thinking if I go here then
he would take and my main plan was
before I want to keep the pawn on b4 but
then the problem is I really wasn't sure
at all about this and I know he's a very
aggressive player my night on g1 is kind
of out of play and it just seems very
tricky and I don't know if I want to go
for this so that's why I think b5 might
have been better I was planning on
taking on d5 not playing I Drive it away
and then after it takes here it's a much
better version because after I've traded
now the pawn on b5 is hanging because I
have traded and we canvassed e6 square
so now you have to deal with this and
then I have time to play F 4 + 9 f3 and
then everything's good white has very
solid position so that was an
interesting idea of b5 and white castles
so before I'm just using space Knight h3
and so I felt yeah it was very good for
me and then he kind of shocked me again
it's c5 very unexpected and I realized
that dark for Bishop is deserting a lot
of influence my nighttime B to getting
fortified shake everything on c5 so
takes takes but still after Knight f2 I
think why should still be much better
because it's like a grew Infeld but my F
pawn is gone but he has no C pawn to
pressure d4 so the centers is very
strong for me
Bishop e7 yeah Quincy - so knives
Knights actually attacks 96 yeah I
didn't know what else you can do Luke c1
the point is the Queen was undefended
and he was threatening to take on d4
because he
pinning the thief on so that's player
work see one looks dating again the same
idea so Queen B 3 now he can't take on
before because I'll take with the pawn
and then the bishop defends the robots
you want so that all these tactical
ideas don't work anymore
and here d5 is probably not a great idea
cuz 95 and I'm not winning a piece and
if I take the pawn on d5 let me just
should break be 595 20 takes beat 5
would be 8 or something like this I'm
not obsessed
no no not here right away start huge
mood tonight probably not f4 and I mean
it's probably good for why I'm a pawn up
but especially with c3 hanging and it
just seems like the type of position he
would be better at than me so I decided
to play it safe and not do anything rash
I just I just catch it
oh sorry tonight g6 yeah Castle I didn't
work for me to domestic position so a6
create - the idea is to get out of 95
attacking my queen and also threatening
this work obviously because there would
be no tempo so 98 respects pretty quick
yeah and here pulling back to b3 I was
very happy with my position bastard rook
c7 he's going to double in the sea
punished week so I had to find a way to
defend that there's also some weird
tactics on d4 so I'm not careful you can
potentially do something nasty for
example so I play Knight d3 or no I
think it was rook c2 then he has
annoying idea root G eight rooks b1 and
I think I'm not a hundred percent sure
but there were some ideas where
especially if my Knights moved he can
potentially take on c3 so let me just
show you an example like if I'm not
careful and I move my knight there is a
very annoying move and now I think I'm
in big trouble because he's taking f3
and the bishop the bishop will attack
the rook again and now I think I'm just
lost
so it has to be very very careful too
risky 7 so I played with
with f d1 or kc8 Bishop d2 so now
there's no funny business on c3 or d4
because I'm not really hanging anything
I just have to be careful not to move by
night too quickly because he still might
have some sacrifice ideas so Queen b6
yeah I have to get the King out of there
I don't want a nonsense on B for some 96
again at D 595 still 94 a nice move for
sin Queen a 7 and a 93 now 95 will be
very strong so he played nine eight five
point eight to ninety four and I figured
my Center was pretty strong so I was
happy to trade pieces here and now my
Knights coming to e3 and then to d5 the
same idea my knight cuts the d5 will be
very good Queen eight and here yeah I
don't know if I should have allowed this
but I didn't see I think after 94 I've
kind of committed myself after community
because if I defend the e pawn he'll go
f5 and then it's kind of a mess because
if I take up five he'll take up three
and kind of awkward on the diagonal so I
figured I was committed to winning the
exchange and it looked really good and
in my head but in hindsight he's a
little hard to win especially you know
he has he has a pawn and a knight but
the positions closed and it's pretty
difficult I have to work very hard here
so Queen be warned yeah bouquet for have
to go back to p2 very annoying position
because one I know it's better but I
mean for example it's very hard because
if you played e6 threatening the a3 pawn
I'm pretty sure ich e5 and then it takes
a three Queen f2 and it takes you one
Queen f6 and that should be game over we
have to take some questions
yeah and here may be king of fate but
now this is now it's just lost when I
shave this ship up six and I take his
eye so this shoe has four he played 96
in 76
rook if you won it's got three
interesting f6 I don't know a lot of six
things like a little weak neighborhood
ambitious b7 this is a nice idea if I
don't have this idea I think it's really
hard because now I'm going to rewrite my
bishops at c5 and put pressure on you
seven this should have definitely well
placed on c5 because it defends all that
weak pawns on a3 and
and there's kf7 we should be sick so
it's pretty happy to find your sensors I
don't think you dare sacrifice the
second exchange that's too much the 98
rookie three my bishop again is a
perfect peach now so it's really happy
about that and I just kind of kept
putting pressure three technical cleanup
five beyond here he was well on time so
I guess you just wanted to trade but I
think this should be much better for me
but then of course i blundered and i
made it hard all over again
the average should before I don't know
about that because now now I forgot
about this move and then now I have to
move my rook I kind of have to do this
there's not really any other options and
now I realized okay so I've probably
made it really hard on myself because
this is going to be difficult especially
this big pawn mass on the Kings side and
I don't know if my eight pumps enough so
I realized this was going to be a very
long difficult endgame here so so
probably yeah probably Bishop before was
a mistake because I allowed the ninety
five tactic wearing like a for Bishop c5
King h1 if King f1 King up one and rook
c2 and then we're get to and it's not
really one I'm going away from the pawn
but I think if the pawn moves I can
catch it pretty quickly
the bishop before yeah that's nice
because I can't play rook a1 because
he'll play like something like risky
three and then I have to go away from
the eight-ball I really want my rook
behind the a pawn but it's hard to do
right away so h4 I want to go age five
and then keep this came from g6 with
four she was king g6 now row k1 no
because there's no back rank so for
example if he plays well it's d we
played basically the rook here then I
can move the rook up and the H pawn is
very useful on h4 because now I don't
have to worry about back rank this
should see three I knew I was losing
aged fun but I figured with my look
behind the a pawn you know and it I
don't see any way from stopping it
should still be good but you know sure
enough he's very tricky
now his pawn mass on the King side is
getting a little scary
King a spot-on about king of flowers
thinking with people I'm checking to be
complicated with just King on a five
kind of blocks is pawned it away and
then kini floor I definitely don't think
he need for I think here are just works
you one and then if King be five you can
chase me further and then go kini for
and then the Ming and my king is so far
away and if you start pushing these
pawns could be very awkward even if you
get the fish above for the pawn even if
I have to expensive rook could be very
awkward to me but now his king is kind
of see how his king is kind of impeding
his pawns from coming forward so I was
connected about that and as we can see
my opponents getting very close to Queen
and so here yeah here comes the point
instead of f4 I think you can probably
draw if she plays b4 and I was thinking
route b7 but after Bishop maybe this
should be three the thing is if I ever
push and try to Queen I don't believe
I'm going to win this I'll probably have
to be careful to draw funny enough
because it spawns are so far my king is
cut off and could be very annoying I
could almost lose so f4 I don't know
about f4 so because now after would be
seven yeah it's probably still okay if
he plays Bishop III but for some reason
he played repeat one I think would be
one is there definitely a step in the
wrong direction because when my king now
if my king gets behind the pawns like
this and again you can see can't push
the pawn because this is hanging so Luke
c8 I think his last last a good chance
was probably route c6
because if King f5 then I think what was
I looking at should Bishop III probably
the thing is he's still pushing his
pawns when the King is kind of out of
play but when he plays rook c8 this is I
think his last mistake now and now it's
pretty much over because after king of a
747 rotate forcing okay now King d5 and
this is where it gets pretty nice for me
because he can't push efore because of
the chicane and the thing is I'm gonna
I'm gonna check him on a3 and if my King
gets to e4 I think it's just lost so I
have to be really careful here maybe
you maybe he has to play like Bishop III
and then for example now now the thing
is she's going to play you for but it's
still kind of difficult for him because
he's not going to be able to move his
pawns because his King is in the way she
was king I'll take appalling before so I
think I might be better there be hard to
win book and King III is losing that's
the last real mistake I think now check
and I'll just over because he can never
move f3 the King on e4 is dominating and
Roque 2 checks coming he's going to be
on the back rank and there's really
nothing he can do and well very nicely
done and even though it was a rough
start of the tournament the last two
rounds certainly went in your favor you
have one I am norm coming into this
event what is your hope for this
tournament are you staying positive
yeah I'm pretty positive the I mean the
norm is six and a half so I needed
basically I only have room for one more
draw after starting with two losses so I
don't really see the norm as you know
such a focus anymore I mean my goal is
just to you know play good chest from
compared to what I started with and
hopefully gain some rating and if I get
the norm that be free fantastic but you
know I'm not making on it though well
it's a good way to think and when you
come into this event you lose the first
two games that's kind of rough on a
player psyche very rough so how do you
deal with that specifically I mean I've
lost so many games it just it used to
hurt a lot more than it does now it's
still painful but you know you just have
to kind of let it go and move on because
you can't do anything about it anymore
it's very annoying and you know you kind
of hate yourself for it but you know the
new games you just move on and then you
can only lose so much so well when it's
all said and done air and hopefully st.
Louis goes down is one of your favorite
places to play because of a positive
memory so congratulations maybe we'll
talk to you later all right let's take a
look at the International master norm
standings after five rounds of play
players in this field eligible for a
norm
however the means to get there is
different for each player for six and a
half points
hoo-ahh Benoa colas Williams and Shankar
will earn an IM norm and due to the
tougher field he will face
Doug Eckert only has to get six points
to earn his I am norm the 2017 st. Louis
winter Invitational continues through
Tuesday February the 21st follow all of
the action including the live games at
us chest champs calm